so the United States is at a Crossroads
in energy policy as that last talk made
clear
um with no price on the emission of
carbon dioxide currently uh low priced
fossil fuels threatened to displace
nuclear power plants and can and curtail
new investments in nuclear energy
uh on top of that the disaster at
Fukushima has renewed questions about
whether regulation can keep nuclear
plants safe and secure so to discuss
these issues uh we're thrilled to bring
together uh several distinguished guests
on this panel
um moderating the discussion will be Don
Elliott Adjunct professor of law here at
Yale law school and a leading scholar
and practitioner of environmental law
he's also senior of council at Covington
in Burling and between 1989 and 1991 he
served as assistant administrator and
general counsel of the Environmental
Protection Agency
um welcome Don and all the panelists and
thank you all for joining us
well thank you very much we have a a
very distinguished panel uh to my to my
right is Allison McFarland who is
Professor of Science and Technology
policy at George Washington University
and um also a former chairman of the U.S
nuclear Regulatory Commission from 2012
to December 2014. so no one in a better
position to talk about nuclear and
nuclear policy than Allison to my
immediate left is uh former Senator Judd
Gregg who served both as governor of New
Hampshire and as a United States Senator
and currently serves as co-chair of the
Leadership Council on on nuclear matters
and is really an expert in nuclear
policy and then to his left David
Christian who is Executive Vice
President and chief executive officer of
dominion generation and also a member of
the board of directors of the nuclear
energy Institute which is a client of
mine among other things
um we have a conflict there as the uh
just said I I teach uh energy policy but
also as was indicated and primarily an
Environmental Lawyer and although I
can't uh represent
um EPA somebody said we don't have
anybody from EPA here
um I think a number of the panelists are
are going to talk about the EPA clean
energy proposal or clean energy proposed
regulation so I thought I'd just Briefly
summarize that for those of you who may
not be familiar with it so someone asked
a question about a national ambient air
quality standard for CO2 I advocated
that in 2008 and I tried to persuade EPA
to do that they decided not to do that
for a number of reasons they decided to
take a sexual approach and to focus on
Transportation with the negotiation of a
new
standards for for mileage fuel economy
standards fleet Fleet economy standards
and then also to focus on the electric
generation sector because those are the
two largest sectors transportation and
energy and the Mainstay of the approach
on oops not going to work huh okay I
should leave it alone
um the Mainstay of their approach is a
proposed rule that came out in June of
2014 called the clean power plan also
sometimes referred to by the section of
the Clean Air Act that is used as
Authority which is section 111 d
and basically that's a a a a a a a a
section of the Clean Air Act that
permits EPA to promulgate procedures and
targets for states to regulate existing
sources of pollution
and there's a controversy about which I
won't go into about whether or not it's
available even to regulate Electric
utilities because they're already
regulated under another section of the
statute section 112 but assuming that
they can regulate Electric utilities
under Section 111 D EPA has proposed a
very Innovative approach which really
amounts to a national energy policy or a
renewable energy policy and they
basically come up with State targets for
CO2 reductions from Electric utilities
by coming up with what the statute calls
the best system of emission reduction
and traditionally that's been just
changes that you can make at the
polluting facility Here For the First
Time EPA is proposing to do what's
called go beyond the fence line and
basically say the best way to control
CO2 from existing electric power plants
is to generate a lot of low low carbon
energy either from natural gas or from
nuclear or for Renewables so they come
up with the take with the state targets
by four building blocks the first is
increasing efficiency at fossil
generation plants the second is greater
use of low carbon generation and there
are two variations of that as originally
proposed they talked about greater
utilization of natural gas plants they
then came out with an alternative saying
well maybe we ought to give credit for
New Generation from natural gas plants
and that's been very controversial
because as was alluded to by Jared and
I'm sure others will talk about if you
if you allow credit for a new natural
gas in terms of the prices you may you
may cause the nuclear plants to uh to
close and we currently get about 20
percent of our electricity in the United
States more or less from from nuclear
it's far and away the largest source of
non-eminine hitting Generations so for
example in Connecticut here we get about
10 times as much energy from nuclear as
we do from all renewable sources
combined so just to give you a sense of
scale
and then the third building block is new
renewable and and new nuclear that's
under that's under construction and the
fourth building block is Energy
Efficiency in a in a proposal that
seemed to please no one EPA proposed to
give States credit for the six percent
of nuclear that is supposedly at risk
and urge states to implement measures to
keep that six percent of nuclear on on
online but it didn't allocate it to the
uh to the states where those nuclear
plants that are at risk are but it
allocated it evenly with a six percent
credit kind of across the board so those
are some of the issues that I'm sure
will come up in terms of whether or not
this proposal really
does does the right thing creates the
right incentives with regard to nuclear
with with that let me just turn to the
panelists to each make a an opening
statement and we just decided
arbitrarily to do it in alphabetical
order so that means uh first uh David
Christian and then Allison McFarland and
and Senator Greg Banning cleanup
okay well good morning or good afternoon
I suppose it's a uh both a pleasure and
an honor to be with you today and to
offer insights that I'm a
regarding the challenges being faced by
commercial nuclear power in the U.S the
subject is particularly timely as the
entire electric sector in the United
States
enters a state of a period of transition
to a lower carbon future I want you to
know that I've got a uh a personal
interest in this intersection of energy
and the environment that goes back quite
some time as a young student
in the mid-1970s
and I was influenced by a course and a
book and I understand that some people
don't know what books are on campus
anymore but uh but as a course
coursework and a book titled technology
and Society written by R.C Dorff so if
there's any electrical engineers in the
room you might recognize his name as a
uh uh
Pioneer of automatic control theory but
anyway the book was an elective in
engineering ethics and the general
coursework was to examine in a
thoughtful and deliberate way the impact
of various Technologies on the planet
and here is a young engineer after
examining the various ways in which we
were generating electric electricity at
that time
I pretty much decided that we were going
to need nuclear energy and I directed
all of my studies in that direction so
with all of the all of the Consciousness
available to a 20 year old back in the
mid-1970s I made that decision
I had been introduced at that time to a
theory which was then called the
greenhouse effect that later took on the
name of global warming and now enjoys
the moniker of climate change and as
soon as to be renamed perhaps to climate
resilience
uh so I do believe it's a an important
uh contribution to uh generating large
scale base load electricity with very
few emissions and I have thought that
for quite some time
um now there have been times in my
career when I've paused to reflect and
say was that a good decision one was the
accident at Three Mile Island that's
been dealt with pretty well here the
other was Chernobyl and the last was
Fukushima
but I still remain convinced that it can
and must play a significant role in the
energy mix of the United States and of
the planet
I was asked in the mid-1990s by one of
my employees hey when are we going to
build the next nuclear power plant and
uh just to take you back to the
mid-1990s
and I said you know
probably sometime in the next decade
2000 to 2010 the statistical evidence
for climate change global warming is
going to become undeniable because in
the mid 1990s there's still quite a bit
of debate about is it real is it not
real
even in the National Labs
now you've got a pretty General
consensus that it is something that we
ought to be worried about
and even the people who are remain
unconvinced will tell you that we ought
to there's uh take some no regrets
actions in that direction
um
but in that time frame we had improved
the efficiency of nuclear power plants
from a utilization factor of about 70
percent up to 90 plus percent and so we
had created through efficiency
improvements the equivalent of 23 new
nuclear power plants in the United
States and in essence we're the victims
of our own success today virtually every
nuclear power plant in the United States
is operating at 90 utilization Factor
those kinds of efficiency improvements
are no longer available to us if it's
going to be used as a tool for climate
mitigation you're going to have to build
more of them
um so fast forward to today I do have
responsibility for uh about twenty four
thousand megawatts of electric power
generation of all types and I mean all
types I have nuclear coal oil gas Hydro
wind pump Storage Fuel Cell solar you
name it if it generates electricity we
do it
uh I'm proud to say that Dominion is the
owner of three facilities in Connecticut
uh five megawatt solar field up in
summers a 15 megawatt fuel cell in
Bridgeport and a 2050 megawatt nuclear
plant in in Eastern Connecticut
that emits essentially zero CO2
uh since assuming my current role in
2009 I have closed down sold or
converted to Natural Gas 21 coal plants
but I've also had to shut down a nuclear
plant in Wisconsin uh 680 megawatt
nuclear plant like to talk about that in
just a few minutes I will tell you that
yesterday I was with the EPA
administrator Gina McCarthy at lunch and
I can assure you that she is and speaks
with conviction
that we are headed for a lower carbon
future and that is in fact the intent of
the clean power plan
for all its benefits and desirability is
a low carbon emitter nuclear power does
face some issues and and this is where I
want to get back to two things one is
the the market conditions out there that
are not
recognizing in a positive way or
sufficiently the attributes of nuclear
as a continuous base load non-emitting
source
and the other is the the financing
challenges of new nuclear power plants
in the United States so with that let me
go back briefly to Kiwani and I'll turn
it over to the other panelists
uh the marginal cost of power in the
Upper Midwest is set by either natural
gas or Powder River Basin coal which is
surface mined out of eastern Wyoming at
ten dollars a ton
the market price of electricity is about
30 dollars per megawatt
uh our Kiwani nuclear plant cost about
fifty dollars to make a MAG about five
cents a kilowatt hour if you will so we
we became unprofitable when gas prices
started to come off and coal prices came
down to about ten dollars a ton
and uh quite simply business is not in
the business of losing money for
shareholders we don't have to we we're
not allowed to fall in love with a
particular asset we don't have a legal
obligation or Duty uh to do things that
protect the environment we make choices
uh in the best interest within the
framework of of Market policy and
regulations to uh to stay in business
and to provide a return to shareholders
that invest in us so we had to close the
Kiwani nuclear plant down but what
happened I just want you to tell you
what happened when that occurred
Wisconsin went from a balanced state to
a net importer of electricity and their
carbon emissions went up by over 5
million tons a year
so there are consequences right now
there's about eight or ten other nuclear
power plants in the United States that
are in in similar Jeopardy of premature
closure uh that are similarly
likely to result in increased carbon
emissions anyway it's uh good to be here
with you I look forward to your
questions and again it's it's an honor
and a pleasure to be here
well uh my name is Judd Gregg and as was
mentioned I serve in the United States
Senate for 18 years and before that I
was governor of New Hampshire was there
when the last major nuclear power plant
was brought online Seabrook uh myself
and Evan by put together a group which
involves a pretty good cross-section of
American public policy people
and we call it nuclear matters it
involves people like Carol Browner who
used to be head of the EPA who was at
one time
fervently anti-nuclear and has
completely changed her views because of
her concerns about global warming
and is now fervently pro-nuclear people
like Spence Abrahams who was Secretary
of Department of of energy and so
we've come together to talk about plants
which already exist and that's why
David's ending is where I'd like to pick
up this is obviously a panel of experts
who know the weeds and know the process
of how nuclear power runs we're talking
about it however from 20 000 feet the
basic public policy implications of
closing nuclear plants which already
exist prematurely like kawani like
Vermont Yankee in my part of the country
these plants and they're about 20
physical facilities which are at risk
and about 10 actual locations
are confronting a
almost a perfect storm of problems which
are driving economic policies which
David outlined as being leading to the
closing of Kiwani the first is that
nuclear power gets no credit for the
fact that is non-carb limiting
that makes no sense you know
as a very practical matter under the new
EPA rules or any proposal which is
pointed at the purpose of getting our
Global emission of carbon out down you
can't get there from here without
nuclear power
certainly in the next 10 20 30 years you
can't get there and that's when all
these plants are operating
at their highest levels
as was mentioned in
David's undertaking here in Connecticut
97 percent of Connecticut Connecticut's
non-carbon emitting
power is nuclear in my state of New
Hampshire it's 87 percent
across the river in New York it's about
66 percent nationally it's about 63 62
percent of all the non-carbon emitting
power in this country is nuclear you
can't take that offline and replace it
with solar or wind or other alternative
Source energies as much as we support
those sources of energy
because there's simply no capacity to do
that within those alternative sources
what they will be replaced with as was
mentioned is carbon emitting
carbon emitting sources and in fact in
Vermont Yankees experience which is more
local to myself in New Hampshire uh the
fact that it's coming offline means that
first prices will go up in one County in
New Hampshire by about 50 percent but
more significantly than that or that's
pretty significant for those folks but
equally significant
you're adding about 114 000 new cars to
the road that's the amount of carbon
that's going to be emitted and the power
will come from outside New England as
versus being produced in New England and
it'll be oil based mostly
the second thing that's driving this
policy was again mentioned which is that
nuclear is reliable energy
it runs 24 7. it runs 90 percent of the
time other energy sources although very
important don't have that type of
reliability record and when we went
through the recent polar vortex which
those of us in New Hampshire experience
rather bitterly uh
it was nuclear that carried us a lot of
regions in this country could not have
gotten power without nuclear because
some of the other power sources were not
functioning because of the cold
third is this whole public policy issue
and this really concerns myself and Evan
bayh of putting too many eggs in one
basket we're moving to gas we understand
that we've had this huge Revolution and
it's a positive for us as a nation the
fact that we now are basically going to
be energy self-sufficient for all
intents and purposes in the next in the
foreseeable future but
you don't want to put all your eggs in
one basket
and when nuclear represents 20 of your
energy base load to take that offline
and move it to gas that's foolish that's
as a matter of strategy and National
Security a foolish decision because you
don't know what's going to happen in the
future
and that's something that we're very
concerned about
the fourth item that is driving this
concern and creating this economic
problems for these plants which by the
way can have a great useful life in
front of them but are going to be turned
off potentially prematurely is the fact
that transmission lines in this country
are aged and so as these plants produce
extra energy in times when the energy is
not needed in their region they can't
get it out they can't move it because of
the Aging infrastructure so what nuclear
matters is trying to do myself and this
group that's come together
is communicate the message of the
importance of these existing plants
we're not talking about new plants
although I happen to very strongly
support new nuclear facilities but we're
talking about
the existing plants which may go offline
before their useful life is up and
saying hey you know this is a cut off
your nose to spite your face policy a
get makes absolutely no sense from a
standpoint of public policy to turn off
all base load production
which is already there and which can
exist into the future for a considerable
number of years you know there's that
old story and it especially applies here
to the issue of carbon reduction because
if you're concerned about global warming
you've got to be pro-nuclear at this
time
uh you there's that old story in New
England up in New Hampshire which we
tell which is
Oscar Payne was about 85 years old was
sitting on his front porch of the local
Country Store and rocking in his chair
and a car from New York pulled up a
great huge Suburban you know big black
one and the person leaned out the window
and said to him how do you get to Pike
New Hampshire from here
an Oscar thought for a minute and said
well
you go up this road take a right nope
no you go back down here about six miles
and you and no no
well there's a road that goes over that
mountain there no no
well you know you can't get there from
here
that's the situation
you cannot get to where we need to get
in the area of carbon reduction
without nuclear power and until we have
policies and this is where we're
hopefully moving towards which reflect
the importance of carbon reduction of
reliability and of diversity
in how you Price Power especially for
existing power plants
we're going to be
paddling Upstream without an ore so
we're making this case it's a public
policy initiative a public information
initiative we haven't put out specific
proposals yet but it's an attempt to
educate folks on the importance of the
existing power plants
okay
all right good afternoon everybody I
hope you're not sleeping from lunch but
I'll try to wake you up a little bit I'm
going to just talk about regulatory
perspectives right now because you get
to hear me again poor you uh drone on
about uh larger issues so I'll I'll keep
my focus small so I want to talk a
little bit about a credible regulator
we've heard on some of the earlier
panels uh the importance of a regular
regulator I think Mark Peters uh talked
about it a bit as well and I think it's
important that we have a credible
regulator and what does that mean
without a credible regulator there won't
be public trust in the system and
without public trust there won't be
support for nuclear power and we've had
a few discussions dancing around this
issue with some of the questions from
the audience already today and uh and so
I'll go on a little bit more about it
public support is lost when the the
regulator is not open and transparent
what do I mean by open and transparent
open means that you are open to having
conversations engaging with the public
meeting with the public on a regular
basis and transparent means that you
make all of your processes and decision
making transparent so that you publish
and make available all of your
documentation and all of your thinking
and unfortunately one thing that the
Fukushima accident highlighted which
I'll explain more in the next talk
um is that there are differences between
how different countries regulate and the
public sees this and so standardization
can be can be important
let me speak domestically for a minute
and then I'll I'll go to more of an
international perspective so some of the
regulatory issues that have come up
um there is some new build in the U.S I
think you've heard it actually five
reactors are under construction one is
an old design that will probably be
completed and up and running later this
year the other four are new designs that
were talked about at the previous panel
and we've had some these these new
plants these four new ones the ap1000s
the Westinghouse plants are licensed
under a new process a combined operating
license and so this has been a a
learning experience for both the
licensees and the nuclear Regulatory
Commission and one of the experiences
and one of the lessons that everybody
has learned is that the licensee is
responsible for any issues that come up
not the contractors or subcontractors to
the licensee but that's a bit in the
weeds for operating reactors you're
right we do uh Senators write that there
are a number of of plants that are um uh
in financial Jeopardy right now but in
terms of regulatory issues we do have an
aging Fleet many of the plants have
reached their 40-year license original
license life they're now been granted
20-year license extensions but with age
incomes issues Replacements of large
Parts Etc and the nuclear Regulatory
Commission has ensured that these older
plants have aging management programs in
place but it's something that that is
going to have to be watched and then
there are reactors like Kiwani which is
now undergoing decommissioning and this
has been another issue uh of late
because a number of plants in the past
couple years have decided to shut down
and permanently decommission and
unfortunately the regulations that exist
for decommissioning plants are the same
ones for operating plants and they don't
make a whole lot of sense in a number of
areas so something that I was able to do
just before I left the nuclear
Regulatory Commission was to ensure that
there will be new regulations for
decommissioning plants that will come
through and hopefully be more
appropriate so that's some of the
domestic issues from an international
point of view and and we heard some of
this in the previous panels as well
there's the majority of new build is
going on elsewhere mostly in China
really the vast majority is going in
China a little bit in Russia a little
bit in India and as I said the U.S has
five plants going up but there are many
countries that have said that they would
like to develop nuclear power
and there's been a lot of talk about
this over the past five or eight years
uh not a whole lot of action but the
United Arab Emirates you see pictured on
the right at the braqqa site here is
building four reactors
uh turkey and Vietnam have signed deals
with the Russians to develop reactors
there are other hopeful countries that
are a little further off and quite a few
others who've actually there are over 60
countries that have said that they would
like to develop nuclear power that don't
have nuclear power
um
the problem is that a number of these
countries these emerging countries have
either weak or
nascent regulators and so let me talk a
little bit about the importance of an
independent regulator and what a
regulator is because you know before I
got involved in the NRC
Regulators kind of put you to sleep I
think but they are really really
important and essential
um first of all it's essential that the
regulator not be influenced by any
politician any political views and it
also should not have any industry
influence it should make decisions
independently it should also have
adequate Financial Resources to do the
evaluations that it needs to do and it
should have adequate expertise on staff
to do these things and of course it
should have the full support of the
central government to be independent
this is not so easy
uh in many places
and it has to have real enforcement
Authority it has to be able to shut down
a plant if it sees that there's a
problem because otherwise it's not going
to be taken seriously
so without an independent regulator I
would argue that a country puts itself
at grave risk of both economic and
public health danger because if
something were to happen they would not
they would not have a way of protecting
themselves
now let me turn to this issue of
standardizing regulations there is no
International body that sets regulations
for nuclear power in all countries
uh and I think Fukushima Fukushima
highlighted some of these these issues
um
pretty well in terms of countries
reactions to the accident and what they
recommended to their people and then
country's reactions after the accident
you might be asking about the
international atomic energy agency they
set guidelines and standards that
countries can choose to adopt if they
wish to but they don't usually there is
something called the convention on
nuclear safety which was established
after the Chernobyl accident as a way to
try to legally require countries to set
High safety standards but this is just
an incentive instrument it doesn't have
any enforcement mechanism the
enforcement is done by peer review which
happens every three years
and I just want to give you a little
example of some of the things that have
happened recently with regards to the
convention on nuclear safety this the
sixth review meeting was a year ago in
Vienna and it was important because it
was an opportunity for countries to peer
review each other's changes after
Fukushima
and some countries wanted explicit
changes that would be codified in the
law of Contracting parties and the only
way they saw that they could do that was
to change the convention itself so the
Swiss government actually proposed
amending the convention and they wanted
to add language that said something to
the effect of should an accident occur
mitigating effects and avoiding the
releases of radionuclides would be
essential and that these objectives
should be applied to operating plants so
in other words you would have to have
new regulations new laws that said that
operating plants could not have an
accident that would emit radiation off
the site
and that made a lot of people
uncomfortable so in the end they decided
there was a diplomatic convention there
was a lot of money spent and Sweat
Equity spent trying to uh
deal with this in the end they made a
Vienna declaration they did not open the
convention which is a good thing because
our Senate would have approved it and
would ask the senator his odds and
whether they would have approved it or
not
um
so uh and
so I just want to end with the again the
importance of the regulator in this
whole process of thinking about the
future of nuclear energy and a tie
between climate change and nuclear
energy so I'll leave it there thank you
so would any of our panelists like to
say something based on the comments of
others David you went first anything in
particular that this stimulated for you
um
I I agree with Allison that a tough and
credible regulator is in everybody's
interest the industry and the regulator
have a common interest as does the
citizenry uh no one wants
um an operation that that might cause
harm to the public so there are
incentives on both sides there are
economic and public relations and and
just common sense incentives on the part
of Industry operators
and the regulator has got a charter to
provide reasonable Assurance of adequate
protection of Public Safety so there's
an intersection there I would say over
the last uh since 1981 when info was
formed that the an attitude of
self-regulation permeates this industry
in a way that is not matched in any
other industry uh the offshore oil BP
situation prompted the offshore oil
industry to take a look at how nuclear
is self-regulating the airline industry
has got some positive features however
none come close to the degree of
self-regulation that exists in the
United States I do agree it does vary
widely around the world
uh I'll just say a brief word about new
nuclear comment on one thing that was
said at lunchtime because we are
preparing for
um the eventuality of small modular
reactors we're participating in
providing customer requirements to usdoe
I spoke with Ernie menes day before
yesterday Dominion has been pursuing an
early site permit in Combined
construction and operating license to
provide the option for future build
and but more close to the uh more close
on the horizon we are a lead plant our
Surrey plant will be a lead plant and
demonstrating subsequent license renewal
Beyond 60 years to 80 years which which
may significantly extend the carbon
mitigating benefit of the existing Fleet
there are three plants that are being
considered for that right now to test
three different Technologies but at
present the the regulatory framework
seems suitable for that the present
state of research seems suitable for
that and we're proud to be a leader in
in vetting out this possibility of
taking a plant that was originally
designed and licensed for 40 years
already licensed renewed out to 60 years
and now we may be able to go out to 80
years that has a profound implications
for for U.S carbon emissions
let me follow up on that in saying that
uh an independent and strong regulator
is absolutely critical to public
confidence
and so much of the nuclear issue is
around surrounds public confidence so
what the nuclear industry is doing which
has been exceptional and
self-disciplining is uh geometrically
improved by having a regulator who
oversees that and can and enforces it
and so that is a critical element of
getting nuclear to be the American
public to be comfortable with nuclear
on in the foreign markets I do think
it's important for us to remember that
American nuclear technology is still
cutting edge technology
and even though we only have five plans
coming online here in the United States
in the foreseeable future across the
world there are 87 plants that are being
built in their 170 plants that are on
the drawing boards
and we would like that to be American
Technology
and it's pretty hard to make the case
that we're going to have American
Technology being sold into these
different plants if we don't have
nuclear as a as a vibrant industry here
in the United States
to not have it be American Energy
American Technology is going to have two
effects one is going to affect jobs here
in the United States but two I actually
think it affects safety because I think
American Technology is much more safety
oriented than maybe some of the other
technologies that have been used
certainly that was true in Russia so uh
I do think it's important for us to
remember that there's a foreign
component
in our nuclear industry that is very
important for jobs in the United States
for export in the United States and for
maintaining a worldwide Fleet that's
safe
uh I'll just say something about the the
foreign markets and then I want to I
have a question for the three of you so
and just going on the Senator's comments
about uh the um the kind of technologies
that might be deployed in these emerging
countries Russia is really being very
aggressive with its model trying to sell
its new model of the vver 1000 it's
light Water Reactor they operate using a
boo model boo build own operate which
means they go to a country they say
don't worry we've got a great deal for
you we're gonna build your plant we're
going to help you finance it we'll
operate it uh and we'll own it and all
you have to do is pay for the
electricity
it sounds like a great deal and
countries are buying it up uh at but
again
the question is do they have Regulators
who are capable of overseeing what the
Russians do
that is I think an important question
out there so I that particular issue is
needs to be approached with a lot of
caution you know on that point
it's a side issue but they're the XM
Banks coming up for reauthorization and
conservatives tend to be opposed to XM
because it's it's a government basically
entering a Marketplace but
as a practical matter
the nuclear industry can't compete
overseas unless it has XM support and
it's a it's something that if you're a
political scientists
major here at Yale you might want to
follow that debate because it's a it's a
fascinating cross current of
conservative ideology meeting practical
real world markets
so can I ask my question sure so you the
two of you especially but you're welcome
to jump in talked about
um the current economic situation that
faces nuclear power and one piece that
you didn't mention but I think from my
analysis Bears on the success or failure
of of nuclear especially on the new
build side is the restructuring of the
electricity markets which occurred a
number of years ago but have now made it
almost impossible to build new plants in
the unregulated markets so the only
place that you see new plants going up
are in the regulated markets
was that a big mistake can can we
reverse that policy yeah I don't know if
it's a big mistake but we're talking to
a bunch of very bright people who are
going to start focusing on that when
they graduate
uh I would say that it is uh at the
present time in the uh at first when she
talks about unregulated electricity
markets if you're not familiar with it
it's probably be a 10 hour lecture to
familiarize yourself with it most people
do not have any idea of how complex the
U.S Electric System is between regulated
deregulated uh independent system
operators in New England are different
than pjm different than miso ercot Texas
runs at different Cal ISO in California
runs it different it is immensely
complex and uh it uh we would like I've
started to see the hand of ferc Federal
Energy Regulatory Commission gently
start to nudge some degree of
commonality in terms of isos but at the
present time I would say yes it's
virtually impossible in a deregulated
Market to obtain financing for a new
Nuclear Power Plant
yeah I had a question along the same
lines and it's for for everyone and that
is that we have a question from the the
floor under what's what conditions would
it have been acceptable for Dominion not
to have shut down the Wisconsin nuclear
plant I wanted to ask a question that's
sort of related to that more generally
and that is in the EPA clean power plan
um EPA urges States as part of their
compliance strategy to to take actions
to ensure that the six percent of
nuclear plants that are supposedly at
risk don't close
um and my question is how do they do
that particularly how are states which
don't regulate the price of electricity
how do they
influence the decision of whether or not
plants will will close or have their
their life extended so what are the
tools that either states have or or will
need in order to to affect your your
decisions to close a plan or not
all right well let me get to the second
question first and answered uh in a way
that I think I heard it I didn't I
didn't read that into the proposed uh
clean power plan and the first rev but
keep in mind it's a it's a draft
and there were there was an opportunity
many opportunities for public comment
and I believe over 3 million comments
have been provided some as little as one
page long some as long as 2 000 Pages
all of those comments uh have been and
are being reviewed by the U.S EPA and we
expect late summer to have the final
rule out so we'll see what the final
rule says uh with respect to the six
percent uh at risk
but I'll reiterate in talking with Gina
McCarthy she keenly appreciates the
value that nuclear brings to the table
and insists that it's got to be part of
the energy mix going forward as we seek
to decarbonize the electric sector to
the degrees that are then intended by
that regulation
insofar as uh uh kiwanaga is I we we did
explore a number of opportunities we
negotiated at length with uh
counterparties up there for power
purchase agreements we actually tried to
sell the plant to larger operators such
as Exelon where they might have been
able to extract uh other efficiencies we
explored we talked to the governor uh I
suppose a reliability must run a
contract could have been entered into by
the state but that would have required a
uh what you know some might have
perceived as a politically risky move
um at the time
we didn't were not able to achieve that
and the short version of the story is
that the plant power plant would have
needed compensation of about five and a
half cents a kilowatt hour to uh to
remain in operation and we couldn't
achieve that
but just uh
leaving aside EPA because you're you're
right that that may well that may well
change a lot of the speakers
have talked about the importance of
keeping existing nuclear power online if
we're going to try to meet our our
carbon goals and I I just be interested
in having all of the panelists talk a
little bit about what kinds of policies
would be necessary in order to uh to to
achieve that in other words people have
said we've got all this nuclear we want
to keep it online
um what are the what are the various
policy instruments that would be
necessary in order to achieve that that
goal and I think that as I understand it
was really the intent of the question
about closing closing down your
Wisconsin nuclear power plant what would
have and what I'm hearing you say and
maybe maybe that's the answer is it's
it's price is there anything other than
price that you really need
well one thing is for certain we would
never compromise on safety goals I mean
so if it were a different type of
factory and a different in an emerging
country you know maybe you cut half of
the o m and try and slash costs
this industry is not about that so we
will never compromise on safety
standards we know how much it costs to
achieve good reliable safe operations so
yeah it basically boils down to price I
think more recently a company has been
in negotiations with the state of New
York about
extending the life of a unit up there
that's under under uh
scrutiny did you want to add some can I
ask a quick follow-up David what happens
to the plan what happens when a nuclear
power plant dies uh Jobs go away tax
base goes away
um
the carbon emissions in the state go up
and it just so happens that about a year
later the one of the incumbent utilities
came back to the state and filed
approval filed for approval to build a
gas plant of roughly the comparable size
so the the really ironic piece for the
economists in the room there's something
called the missing money problem and if
you haven't you can read about it in
Tuesday's Wall Street Journal
but uh the market was compensating us at
about 30 to 35 dollars we needed about
50 to 55 we shut the plant down and now
it's being replaced for something that's
got a levelized cost of 70 to 75 dollars
so
um the markets are not
there there may be Market flaws that are
not adequately compensating these units
uh for the attributes they bring to the
table yes
to be monitored I would assume oh
absolutely yeah the the nuclear fuel is
still there there's a lengthy process by
which you have to get the fuel out get
it into dry casks and and all the time
you've got to take adequate measures to
protect public from from anything that
could happen we have a large security
Force still there so there's there's a
number of things so but it's so it's a
long ramp and eventually the monies have
already been accumulated it's something
a lot of people don't realize is that
nuclear power is really the only
large-scale form of electric power where
all the costs have already been
internalized we've saved the money for
decommissioning that's already been
provided for the um the funds to dispose
of spin fuel have already been
accumulated so all of the externalities
have already been included in the costs
I think you're going to see
some states try to address this issue
and move away from spot pricing to
giving credit for
lack of carbon emission because they're
going to be under pressure to do that to
keep the carbon emissions down
to give credit for reliability
and to give credit for diversity
Illinois is actually wrestling with this
issue right now in their state
legislature and they may end up being a
template for how a state addresses this
issue
in terms of the the shutdown you know
you guys have a experience locally with
a decommissioned plant the what was
called Adam neck Connecticut Yankee yeah
Cy
and as far as I know it's now down to
just the spent fuel pad right so it's
Greenfield just like manianki is in
Yankee row all the Yankees got
greenfielded except for the spent fuel
so All That Remains is the spent fuel
we have several questions from the floor
one is
what a cut in unnecessary sources of
carbon emissions a major example of
which is animal agriculture paren 18 of
CO2 emissions more than all
Transportation combined
would would cutting those emissions not
be more effective than investment in new
and expensive technology that we do not
yet have a sound understanding of I'm
not sure what the new and expensive
technology is maybe maybe Renewables but
in any event what what what about
reducing other sources of carbon
emissions like like animal agriculture
I guess the only thing I could offer
there is if a if a state under the clean
power plan offers that to the EPA as a
mechanism for compliance
then I think the EPA would have to
consider it although the the rule tends
to apply strictly to the electric sector
I think there'd be certain political
issues that you might run into
called Farmers yeah I think that's one
of the key issues is that historically
EPA has found it easier to focus on
automobiles and Electric utilities in
part because they're concentrated so
it's a little easier to regulate them
and it's also easy to regulate them
politically when you have something
that's very spread out like animal
agriculture it's just harder from an
environmental standard there's no
stronger political Lobby in the Congress
than the agriculture I will say this
that no one on this panel or any panel
today pretends that nuclear power is a
silver bullet or the only answer I mean
efficiency is going to make a big
difference in the amount of power
consumption that that occurs in the
United States so we've already seen in
recent decades a flattening of our
energy intensity so we're we've got for
the same amount of GDP we're using less
and less electricity so efficiency plays
a big role mm-hmm absolutely absolutely
okay next question one major barrier to
overcome with nuclear energy is public
perception and support many fear the
perceived dangers of nuclear or have a
not in my backyard mentality how can the
media and films like Pandora's promise
and public education help the nuclear
community's case so how do we deal with
Public particip public perception issues
you know that's what we're trying to do
with nuclear matters specifically we're
trying to raise the awareness of people
as the importance of the role of nuclear
power in their everyday electrical needs
you know when a person walks into their
home they turn on their lights they
don't care where the power comes from
they just want the lights to go
and
when the lights don't go on they get
very upset
and and the point we're trying to make
is those lights may not go on or they
may go on sporadically or the power
that's putting them on may be affecting
your environment
so why don't you seriously look at
nuclear power as an option and it's
having resonance it's having fairly
significant resonance in fact when
somebody like Carol Browner
who was one of the most activists she
she takes credit for this one of these
most active people in opposition to
nuclear power in the 60s and the 70s
completely changes her position because
she recognizes that global warming in
her opinion is the single biggest
concern we should have as a culture from
a standpoint of our long-term existence
uh as a planet
and becomes a strong advocate for for
nuclear
that shows that folks of reason
who have historically maybe come out of
a culture that said nuclear power was
not the right way to go especially the
16th during the 60s and 70s I rethinking
the issue and
if you are of Reason common sense as we
refer to it in New Hampshire then you've
got to give credit where credits too
which is that you cannot get there from
here as I said if you're going to try to
reduce carbon emissions unless you use
nuclear power as a major component of
that for the foreseeable future
so I have a slightly different view from
the questioner who's appealing to
education of the public to improve the
perception I think that's I personally
think that's the wrong way to go
that it's not about educating the public
that's a basically a patronizing point
of view you know if they only knew as
much as me I think it's very important
to enter into conversation to engage
with the public and discuss their
concerns and uh be open about it this is
something that I tried to do at the
nuclear Regulatory Commission because
the NRC does do a lot of public
engagement but it tends to be one one
way and I worked with the industry and
and I was very impressed with with some
parts of of the nuclear industry and
their ability to try to reach out to the
public for example the one of the new
plants the one that I mentioned that's
coming on this year watch bar
it's in Tennessee
they have a public engagement panel and
they recently expanded it to beyond the
nuclear supporters to some of the
nuclear detractors and they've gotten a
lot of really positive feedback because
they've taken the time they meet with
folks they answer their questions they
demystify it they bring people onto the
site show them the reactor that's the
kind of Engagement that I think is is
really important
um and you know mounting education
campaigns it's been tried for many
decades I think you've got enough data
to show that it hasn't worked
you need a new approach and just from an
academic standpoint that that's really
what all the literature shows that it
has to be really an interactive process
on a not a one-way process here's a good
question it's for Allison but also for
the other members of the panel is it
possible to compare nuclear regulation
in a country such as France with the
United States are there advantages
disadvantages in the in the two systems
and I might might broaden that a little
bit while you're thinking about it too
why are there such differences
internationally in the acceptability of
nuclear power in in various countries
you have countries like Germany that
have was mentioned before decided to
shift away from it as I understand it
basically not really very controversial
right across the border in in France
um so are how do we understand these
these very large differences in terms of
public exceptions of nuclear power and
does it have something to do as the
questioner suggests with the with the
structure of the regulatory system no
I don't think it has anything to do with
the structure of the regulatory system I
think it has to do with culture and I'm
not an anthropologist but I refer you to
them to to help explain the differences
um
and you know in in terms of they drink
wine in France and they drink beer in
German and they drink wine in Germany
too uh and they drink beer in France too
anyway I think it's uh it's they're
they're just cultural differences and
and Germany has long been skeptical of
nuclear power so this recent move away
from it as a result of Fukushima is
really not a surprise that they were
going there and they're not the only
ones who made that decision you know
this this the Swiss did as well and
um the the Italians had been thinking of
restarting their nuclear power program
and after Fukushima decided not to so
it's they're not alone and some
countries have had no reaction I mean in
the United States the reaction hasn't
been so severe it's been more of an
awareness that nuclear safety is
important and so people who'd sort of
stop paying attention to their local
nuclear power plant have started paying
attention again and that's where the the
importance of engaging with them I think
is is
is to be found but in terms of the
differences in in nuclear Regulators
around the world there's no one right
way to regulate
uh there are a number of approaches that
will work equally well
but I think the important thing is that
The Regulators talk to each other which
they do and that they learn from each
other because there's no point in
Reinventing the wheel if somebody else
has figured out how to solve a
particular problem so did you want to
add something well I
I tend to agree on the cultural comment
I've been in 92 plants on four
continents including South Africa Russia
China Korea Japan Finland France England
Canada but so the one thing as a nuclear
operator that I have a slight concern
about is that every country has a
tendency to think they do it best
and the reality is that no one can be
complacent this is a demanding
technology and everyone has to pay
attention and to think that you do it
the best is to me a slight measure of
complacency and I would dissuade people
from that
including in the United States so it
requires it's a demanding technology
one one question that you referred to
Allison is learning from regulation in
other in other countries what would be
some examples of the kinds of things you
think we might be able to learn from the
French
the French everybody you keep marching
the poor French out
well that was the question was about
that but um I mean I think a lot of
people have perceived France as one of
the countries that has been most
successful at least in terms of public
acceptability
um so I just wonder if you think there's
anything we can learn from them or it's
just such a different country that we
really shouldn't learn from now you know
the one one point of contention right
now between the European Regulators
French included and the U.S is that the
European regulators and actually most
other Regulators like Canadians Etc do
something called a periodic safety
review
so every 10 years they don't they don't
license their plants uh for 40-year or
20-year chunks every 10 years they do a
full review of their plant
and they say that's the right way to do
it
we don't do that in the United States we
license our plants for 40-year junk or
20-year chunk and we say that's good
enough but what we do in the US that
they don't do in other countries is that
we have inspectors at least two NRC
inspectors who work full-time at each
plant they are there all the time
they're in they're inspecting the
facility all the time so we have
real-time information on any kind of
problems that are cropping up whereas in
other countries inspectors may show up
once a month once every couple weeks
it's a so there's a there's just a
different ways of doing it
okay we have some additional questions
um here's one that was focused
particularly on David but I think any
anyone can address it
um
question is rather than taxing carbon to
make it more expensive can we support
nuclear
um can I say that again well the
question is rather than taxing carbon to
make it more expensive can we support
nuclear I think maybe you've already
answered that when you said nuclear
alone can't really solve the problem but
I think the question was do we need a
carbon tax Oh you mean a like a nuclear
subsidy yeah what do they say rather
than making carbon rather than taxing
carbon to make it more expensive can we
support nuclear so the question would be
rather than negative incentives to
increase the cost of carbon emitting
generation could we do this by
additional subsidies to nuclear and
other non-emitting generation and I
don't know if that's the best way to get
added policy development um you know
best left of policy experts if we can
get them to focus on it and consider a
number of Alternatives there may be
different ways of uh getting at the
problem the the you know the presently I
would say if you tried to Subs you know
the policies generally don't uh are are
derived to not favor or ideally not
favor any particular fuel you want to
you want to generate policy a policy
framework that allows businesses to make
decisions that will generate the result
that you want but uh
so I I you know I guess in theory I can
understand it it might be possible but
um you know but uh
I don't have a policy answer for that do
either of you want to comment on that
I think a carbon tax is some kind of
price on carbon and tax is just the most
straightforward way of doing it with all
the provisos of trying to make it
Revenue neutral Etc
is the easiest way to approach this
problem but I don't know you know for
utility companies that own a variety of
energy sources I don't know if this
makes a difference to you because it's
going to hurt your
carbon emitting side but help the
non-carbon emitting side but if it's uh
if it's Federal and it's applied
Nationwide it's uh I think
a more Equitable way of doing it than
perhaps say the rggi or something
yeah just not going to have a carbon tax
that's not politically doable
it's a value-added tax
and it's not going to pass a congress
even if Congress went back to a
different makeup simply not going to
happen so this issue has to be addressed
without presuming that you can move to a
carbon tax because it's not going to
happen yeah just to comment on it and
that is that um we've we've tried for a
number of years to encourage Renewables
and and low carbon generation through a
variety of subsidies
um and I'm not sure that we can uh push
that even farther than we have to have
to have to date I think the other thing
to remember is that the subsidies at
least that they have to go through
Congress are influenced by the uh by the
political Dynamics in the in in the
Congress uh and so
oftentimes uh existing systems may be
better able at getting subsidies there
there is a report by the environmental
law Institute that claims the subsidies
for fossil energy are much larger than
those for renewable energy which
reflects the political Dynamic rather
than maybe what might make sense from a
policy standpoint so here's another
question which is uh for you but anybody
can can address it does a wind water
solar only grid change the strain the
old transmission system more so I don't
think we've ever had a wind water solar
only grid but I take it the question is
does increasing Reliance on non-nuclear
Renewables put particular challenges on
the on the on the grid
well I think that as a practical matter
to the extent we can get more Renewables
the better off we are
but the grid is
the Grid's problems are not unique to
Renewables or to fossil or to nuclear
what's unique is that nuclear runs so
efficiently and in such a Continuum so
it's a 90 operation that there are a lot
of times the nucleus producing power
that the power can't actually be moved
because of the transmission lines now
that may be true also with wind in
certain parts of the country it may be
true of a solar and certain parts of the
country but it's a real significant
problem for nuclear because of its
reliability levels which are 90 is
versus some of these other sources so
you know let me just mention uh we like
Renewables too but about 250 megawatts
of solar last year we've got 282
megawatts of wind I will tell you that
on the day of the polar vortex January 7
2014 the wind output was substantially
zero
uh either due to no wind or due to
blades having iced over
when I first got this job I first place
I went was out to the National renewable
energy lab to figure out where all this
was headed and talked to the smartest
people in the country about it
and I was looking at the frequency
response of solar panels to Cloud
passage in the eastern United States the
output goes from 90 percent to
essentially 10 in one second
on cloud pathogen and that does create
some technological Challenge and I think
over time those will get solved by
technology
but at present our analysis is that at
about 30 percent renewable penetration
On Any Given circuit you can create
instabilities at the distribution level
and those instabilities will transmit up
into the transmission system because
Transformers work both ways so you know
there's a Renewables are coming you're
going to see a lot more of them there's
absolutely no question about it you're
going to see more solar you're going to
see more wind
I doubt if you'll see more Hydra there's
more dams being taken down in the U.S
than being erected but you're going to
see a lot more Renewables going forward
and it's going to supplant perhaps some
retiring coal and uh and some older
inefficient plants that there's there's
a lot of engineering challenges coming
with it
so one way to think about the problem is
that the transmission grid was built to
service the pre the previous energy
Supply system so you've got grid going
from the places we were we were
generating energy previously to where
the load centers are and if Renewables
such as solar or wind the preferential
locations for those don't happen to be
in the same locations as you previously
had power plants by definition you're
going to have to build some more Grid in
order to be able to get the renewable
into it right so that's going to be a
challenge one way or the other so here's
the next question are there many there
there are many nuclear power stations in
China do you think the regulation policy
is good enough so I don't know who wants
to take on the Chinese Regulators I
can't say I I'm very familiar with the
Chinese regulation policy but uh they
have
they have a number of nuclear plants
they're very ambitious
they've got a lot under construction
keep in mind though that even though
they're doing all this construction and
maybe they'll have close to 100 plants
and another I don't know 20 years or so
that is really
so small in terms of the amount of
electricity they use it is almost
Irrelevant in terms of their carbon
output because they use so much coal and
and even though they're building nuclear
as fast as they can
it's it's really not going to make that
much of a difference sadly
in China so they really China needs a
whole a lot more than just nuclear
my understanding is they've made a
national decision not to build
additional coal plants but but to have
all the growth take place in nuclear and
Renewables we'll see whether or not they
can do that but that's what I understand
their their goal is
anybody else want to comment on Chinese
regulations again beginning when
no I I've visited a couple other plants
and and they seem to be constructed to
Western standards and uh I think the
focus has got to be on good solid
operator training and and performance
so here's another question can you talk
about msrs
I take it that's modular small reactions
well they said msrs
molten salt reactors who who ask about
msrs and what do they mean molten salt
reactors okay and thorium from
Regulatory and other perspectives so
these are some emerging Technologies in
the nuclear field
uh you know what I've only recently
become become aware of some very
interesting things happening in the
thorium space but it I see it it's it's
far enough down to planting Horizon
where it doesn't
doesn't get a lot of attention uh for me
on a day-to-day basis and similarly with
molten salt so they're
it's good that we're doing the research
the doe is you know spending money and
allocating research Monies to small
modular reactors going forward and maybe
even molten salt reactors but
as on our planning Horizon which is a
15-year planning Horizon we submit a
plan
every year that looks out 15 years they
don't show up
yeah I would say that in terms of
dealing with climate problem they are
not going to be your answer
okay not in this time frame
in terms of the regulatory aspects
you know we we do occasionally NRC did
when I was there hear from people who
say oh you know you're not going to be
prepared well
somebody actually has to have a design
that works that is beyond what's on a
piece of paper or is you know at
laboratory scale this big
um you have to have a design that works
you have to have a plan and then you
have to submit a design certification
application and that takes that will
take some time to do but nobody is is
anywhere close to that they are decades
off
so this is not something that's going to
help anywhere in the near term when we
need it
Don do you have many more written
questions I'm going to suggest if there
are any two more direct questions from
the audience uh two more questions and
then when we do that and then we'll open
it up there so this next question really
is is two separate questions so I'm
going to segregate them let the
panelists respond to them separately the
first question is the first statement is
the Fukushima accident showed a weakness
in the way nuclear plants operate and
are regulated so I guess we'll segregate
that off and see whether or not people
agree with that
I don't particularly agree that it shows
a weakness in the way they're operated
but I think it shows a weakness inciting
and design
although the the some of the root cause
work that's still being done does have
elements of operations in it I will
agree with that and I do think
culturally uh the ability to learn site
to site in Japan is not as robust as it
is in the U.S
I agree and I'm going to talk more about
this in in a few minutes so stay tuned
the second half of the question is how
do regulations and the industries
response to regulations take a
risk-based approach into account and
then it goes on to say Obviously a
seismic event or a flood someplace like
Louisiana or Arizona is a small
probability but an incredible amount of
resources being dedicated to these
initiatives so I guess the question is
are do we regulate on a risk-based basis
hahaha
next question okay next question
I this will be the last one then we'll
open it up for the floor you see
regulated States like Georgia Florida
South Carolina making long-term
investments into nuclear do you see
deregulated markets as short-sighted and
do you see these states moving back to
regulated models
I guess this is the question about
regulation that you ask ask earlier and
I ask in a different way about how to
how to how do you provide inappropriate
incentives and deregulated States
uh your the root of the I mean the
ultimate questionnaire is do I see a
movement or do we see a movement I I
don't see a movement I think at present
we're in a transitory state where
there's a great number of unknowns uh
regarding uh distributed generation
rooftop solar uh
uh other other factors so I don't see a
movement in deregulated States back to
regulation but I do see concerns on the
part of State regulators and state
citizens on the um the availability of
their nuclear plants to do to fulfill
their mission so in in Illinois in New
York there is a focus on okay there's a
problem let's see if there's a way to to
solve this it's fair to everybody
one alternative that you're seeing some
places is building other factors like
reliability into the instructions that
the independent service operators take
into account so currently in a
deregulated state if you have an
independent system operator they tend to
dispatch based on price alone and what
we're what we're seeing developing
somewhat is the notion that either Indus
either nuclear or Renewables is saying
there are other factors in addition to
price that should be taken into account
that's without necessarily abandoning
the deregulated Market but just building
some of these other quality factors into
the instructions that the independent
system operators using I do see a focus
at the Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission and elsewhere about let's
value the attributes appropriately and
then dispatch and what we haven't done
maybe to date is value the attributes
appropriately so questions from the
floor
I have a question for Miss McFarland
you said that in China
even with the nuclear plants that
they're going to build it will be a very
small fraction of their electricity
generating capability we are at roughly
20 percent what are they aiming for
that's a good question I don't have
those numbers maybe somebody else does
here one of you climate guys no I don't
think they have a Terminus but but I
think if they build 50 plants they'll be
at about eight percent yeah
yes
I'm probably loud enough I can ask
the question and it's related to
government policy there was a mention of
how successful the Russians have been by
there be by uh
they also have discussed fuel take back
yes they have yeah
I'm very much interested in nuclear
safety worldwide because the
implications it can have on our own
industry right and given the issue
collaboration in particular were some of
the emerging countries who really don't
want to deal with nuclear waste
because they'll have small programs is
there any possibility that the U.S
government would have a fuel payback
program to support National policies
well I'm pretty skeptical because we
can't even solve our own nuclear waste
policies
I think when you see the debate that's
going on over the exim bank
you're not going to anything that would
even take that up leap that would be a
leap of further
in federal subsidy of international
activity and nuclear construction I
don't think it'll happen Regis I don't I
don't see the fuel take back piece but
there is one element of integration that
is being attempted and that is uh on the
on the fuel supply side in other words
the Russians will say We'll mine it for
you we'll Mill it for you we'll enrich
it for you or convert it enrich it
fabricate it and then we'll take it back
so the U.S essentially has or very
little if any remaining enrichment
capability and I believe that Centrist
is now trying to figure out a way to at
least virtually integrate on the supply
side to where the U.S maintains
enrichment capability and does not have
to rely on the Russians the Chinese or
or some other country to uh to provide
enriched fuel uranium Force
um so I have a question for Mr Greg
coming back to the carbon tax
um you know a lot of the discussion this
afternoon has been about the economic
factors of different Supply and
different kinds of Power
but this is all in the backdrop of a
kind of threat to human welfare that we
all see as Grave and arguably rivaling
that from the events of 9 11 or even
Pearl Harbor you know 60 years ago but
as a species of course we're much more
used to threats from external Nations
attacking us rather than you know
natural factors that that the crew over
over decades
so I guess another question is are we
really smart enough to to see this
global warming as a factor that's
equivalent to an external Threat by some
foreign power and and respond and not
really ask so diligently or so so
excitingly about the economic aspects
well that's a good question
you know the marketplace of ideas in the
United States is extremely diffused and
very robust
and there are a lot of different views
on almost any topic that you want to
pick
but I think generally what you're seeing
in the global warming debate is that
most people on both sides of the aisle
are
are taking the view that if you can do
something that is logical and doesn't
necessarily require some sort of
extraordinary action that would be
ideologically unacceptable such as a
carbon tax
then why not do it
if if the outcome is that you you're
probably doing some benefit to the
global warming issue which is why the
debate on nuclear power and keeping
existing plants running has so much
viability quite honestly on both sides
of the aisle
so I I do think
that issue is not being addressed in the
context that you're talking about which
is this is a threat to the United States
we've got to do something immediately
but it's being addressed more in the
context of
yeah it's a problem that we should
address if we can address it without
fundamentally changing ideological
positions and I think a lot of things
come together that allow that to happen
on a number of areas whether it's
alternative energy or whether in fact
when I left the Senate interestingly
enough which just shows how
naive we were as Senators on the
Republicans caucus our policy last year
I was there energy policy was built 100
new nuclear plants and have half the car
Fleet in America be Electric
by we didn't pick a specific date 2050
2030. so you can see that there is
Convergence of ideas here to accomplish
basically what we think is good policy
for a lot of reasons one of which is
addressing global warming so I I think
it's I think the opportunity is there
I wouldn't say your your your question
or your statement reminded me of
something I heard at a student a s
chapter meeting one time which was
nuclear power will have the last laugh I
only hope it isn't too late
um so we heard this morning that France
transitioned from eight percent nuclear
energy to 70 percent within a decade uh
how are they able to move so fast and
why can't we do the same
France again
well I'm not quite so sure that it went
from eight percent to 70 within 10 years
and we did go through a period of very
uh of a lot of build in the 1970s to
early 80s ourselves so you know you you
can you can ramp up
um quickly if you want to I can tell you
what the french Ambassador said the
answer to that question was they did a
program in Washington that I attended
about their nuclear program
and basically they had decided that they
were after Fukushima that they were too
heavily dependent on on nuclear and they
were going to reduce their dependence on
nuclear to 50 percent
and basically what they said is
the cabinet just made this decision so
it's a parliamentary system we don't
have the separation of powers and so on
that we that we have they were able to
just make a so it's a it's a it's a
central planning system with a
parliamentary system you don't have
these pesky issues that we have of
getting things through the Congress uh
the the Prime Minister and the
government are all unitary in a
parliamentary system so that's great if
you make the right decision you can
implement it quickly the problem is uh
if you're if you're wrong you're really
wrong I have an article about this
called why the United States doesn't
have a renewable energy policy so you
can but a lot of it has to do with our
separation of powers it's much it's much
easier for China or France to Simply
make make a decision and then implement
it
plant that's being decommissioned in
Wisconsin why is it that we see it
replaced by natural gas and not by a new
nuclear plant at the same site
uh utilities when they plan to meet
future life I'm not exactly sure how
Wisconsin makes its decision but
typically
uh regulated utilities have to provide
in what's called an integrated resource
plan that looks out 15 years and
actually kind of tries to look beyond
that to 25 years look at the various
costs of generation based on in terms of
installed Capital cost and projected
commodity costs a natural gas or coal or
oil
and you put that into a linear program
and a linear program and you have to
look at load growth what your customer
load growth is going to be and you put
all those inputs into a linear program
and it spits out at least cost solution
and so quite simply gas today is a least
cost solution for for meeting customer
demand that's why Judd Greg here would
refer to this concern about eventual
over-reliance on natural gas as a
primary electricity fuel supply and
putting all of our eggs in one basket
but that's that's the answer that the
linear program gives you then they
present that to the state Corporation
Commission who has to make a
determination on it that that is in fact
a prudent decision and once the prudency
review is done then the utility goes and
builds it so in a sense there's an
externality in the cost of natural gas
which is the uncertainty in in the
future cost that's not being
internalized in this uh it it is to the
extent that we can predict commodity uh
prices in the future now that history
would show is subject to some debate but
uh you're right it is but you have the
externality of the the carbon there is
no price on carbon today so you have a
major externality and the uh and the
natural gas appears cheaper because
you're not taking into account
potentially the carbon effects over time
so there is an externality
yeah
that's it Con we can do final remarks or
we can
close the session
well I'll offer the other panelists of
the opportunity to make final remarks if
they want to delay people from getting
to the coffee break
up to them
I admire you for sitting through it and
becoming more educated and and
developing a perspective an enriched
perspective by hearing a variety of
speakers today nuclear is important
today it's going to be important in the
future
and I thank you for your attention
I would sure
um
I think that you're getting a sense from
the discussion we've had some of the
complexities associated with with
nuclear power uh and I think they're
important to
talk about them and explore them and
understand them uh from the financial or
economic side the regulatory side the
policy side uh and in a little while
I'll talk about the safety side
if you're interested in further
information on nuclear matters please go
to our website and we'd be happy to have
you participate thank you with that
thanks I want to thank all of our
panelists for a very stimulating
discussion thank you very much
foreign